back with this fox news alert a major
development today in the murder of
former st. Louis Police Captain David
Doran trace Gallagher standing by with
the latest for us tonight hi trace hi
Martha David Dorn was shot while he was
inside Lee's pancha protecting it from
looters and police have now released
surveillance video also from inside that
pawn shop that shows seven people
crawling one after another
beneath the security gate into the store
at least two of the suspects are armed
and one of them points a gun at the door
now it's unclear at what point David
Dorn was shot but police say he was hit
by gunfire inside the shop and was able
to make it outside where he collapsed on
the sidewalk the suspects as you can see
were wearing masks but the video is very
clear and police are hopeful that
somebody will recognize them and if you
do call st. Louis police David Doran was
a st. Louis police captain for 35 years
before retiring and taking a job as a
small-town police chief Dorn the father
of five grandfather of ten was also
instrumental in mentoring numerous young
people who were interested in pursuing
law enforcement I just want to note that
Lee's pawn shop is on Martin Luther King
Drive
Martha hmm indeed it is tres thank you
very much so that news coming as calls
to defund or lower funding for police
across the country continued to rise up
nationally you've got some leaders in
Minneapolis taking things further they
want to completely dismantle the police
department in favor of a new
transformative force that would protect
people apparently after the death of
George Floyd the City Council they are
holding an emergency meeting today and
they reached an agreement with the state
to ban police from using choke holds
along with some other reforms what I
just want to go to you first on this
because one of the things that I find
really disturbing in this David Doran
story you know we all are sympathetic to
George Floyd horrified by what we saw on
the video in the evil in the officers
face who was able to snuff his life out
the way he did but my question is where
is the protest
across the country for David Dorn why do
we not see similar outcry for this man
who was 38 years on the police force as
trace pointed out father of five
grandfather to ten people where is the
outcry oh I think that I think these
criminals should be prosecuted with the
full force of the law Martin I think
that you're going to see any hesitation
about that coming not only from the st.
Louis Police Department but from the
people of st. Louis black white Asian
Latino it's a horrific thing to see a
man who served his community in that way
lose his life to these criminals so you
ask though is as if you know mr. Dorn
and the police department and the
politicians in st. Louis don't have
voice of course they do and they have
the power to exercise that I think in
the other case you're talking about
people who feel like a problem has been
ignored not given voice and they are
taking to the streets in peaceful
protest to say we need to deal with a
problem a problem of course that you
properly depicted you know somebody
putting their knee on someone's neck for
nine minutes and the other officers
standing around just a quick note here I
think that these calls to defund the
police are I don't I don't have much
respect for it to be just quite brutally
honest I mean to me poor communities
need the best policing and if you're
talking about money as I was saying
yesterday we don't need you know excess
military equipment after Afghanistan
pouring in making it look like the
police are military force but we do need
strong policing sometimes maybe more
money for better community policing for
better outreach just to improve the
quality of what we have in terms of
police community relations yeah Greg
about this idea to defund the police
departments in some places you've got
Jeremiah Ellison who is keith Ellison
the Minnesota early attorney general's
son saying that he wants to dramatically
rethink the way that we keep people safe
as he puts it in
Minneapolis what do you think he is a
fan of anti faso his opinion means
nothing I tried to be nice in the a
block but that's out the window if you
wanted to fund the police go for it any
celebrity who endorses it 900 block
their number right and any gun dealer
every gun dealer should never sell a gun
to somebody who wants it to fund the
police because what they are doing when
they're purchasing a weapon is they're
getting security for themselves while
denying it for you
alright so I say go for it speaking of
guns how do you think gun control as an
issue was gonna fair after the
Democratic National Convention hit the
streets right that spectacle of
lawlessness effectively did more to end
gun control than anything the NRA could
ever dream of you are watching people
buy more guns than ever before and I
include myself in that so now that gets
to my last point that I wanted to say at
the end of the a block you know what
Trump does something considered good
what is always the criticism well he
should have done it sooner you know he
should have shut down travel sooner you
know we should have shut down the the
city sooner well when Juan said you know
how great it was that we saw these
peaceful protests well I would like to
say I wish it would have happened sooner
because then my neighborhood wouldn't
have been destroyed and decimated and I
wouldn't be looking at people trying to
rebuild their lives maybe it could have
been done sooner I mean how would you
feel if your neighborhood was destroyed
you know what great example Chris Palmer
you got to look up his tweets he looked
at he tweeted while rioters burned down
low-income housing he tweeted burn it
all down and then when the rioters got
to his gated community he called the
cops see the shift everybody can talk
about and wax romantic about the
movement and how we need systemic change
because it means nothing until they get
to your door and then it all goes out
the window
Katie it's great point people have never
owned guns in their lives
people have never owned guns in their
lives who are now thinking about getting
them and I think this is going to be a
very tough selling point for for
Democrats who have been in favor of more
gun control and cracking down and more
background checks it's going to be a
tough argument I think in this
environment yeah you know the gun
control issue and the gun rights issue
and the role of the Second Amendment
during the pandemic and during the
recent spate of riots around the country
is one that we don't have time to fully
just discuss here but it proves again
that we have a lesson to learn and that
is when the police are dealing with
criminals
you are left on your own to defend
yourself and your family you are your
only defense and you are the last
defense so Greg welcome to the club
congratulations I'm glad that you've now
joined that's good but in terms of
martha t a question about democrats and
the selling to the rest of the country
you know politically this is a very
tough issue for them here's a poll that
came out today from Maris and NPR that
shows that 56% of registered voters not
just Americans but registered voters
says that they believe the police have
responded to these situations either
correctly or not aggressively enough and
so this idea that you're going to define
the police comes from far-left people
it's an elitist argument that punishes
the very people of the most vulnerable
people that they claim to be standing up
for and that is the bottom line yeah I
mean I think for the first time in most
of our lives Jesse we got the feeling of
of not of the potential of not having
any protection out there and then you
talk about potentially defunding police
departments and making them weaker and
we already know that that the situations
we've been watching do in some cases
make police back off in certain
interactions they just don't want to go
there necessarily which is a dangerous
thing and now that I know that Greg's
packing I'm gonna be a lot nicer to him
in the green room you can definitely bet
for sure but just put yourself in the
mind of a criminal here because if you
hear people are gonna slash the budget
for the police you're thinking yourself
alright great let's pop the champagne
let's start the crime spree
that means less squad cars less
helicopters less firepower less
detectives less drug sniffing dogs less
task forces I mean you're just gonna run
wild because now there you're gonna
resist arrest more because people aren't
gonna be able to call for backup
there's gonna be slower response times
for crimes it's gonna go crazy what
people don't understand is most of the
police in the inner city they're not
shooting it out with gangbangers like
you see on TV every day you know what
they're doing they're they're helping a
homeless guy who's fallen into the
subway they are breaking up a fight
outside of a bar they're helping a child
that has injured themselves they're
responding to a domestic disturbance
where someone's getting hurt they're
actually trying to help people and
answering calls from people who are
saying please come and help so everybody
go watch live PD this weekend it's live
and you can see they're not there to be
mean bad guys they're there to help
Jesse that's on against a horse show in
my show
DVR live PD coming up we'll be live well